[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
roof
you can get it
[Music]
hello i'm mike brown creative director
at
playground games and i can't wait to
show you
what we've been working on horizon is
known for fun
freedom and beauty this year the horizon
festival arrives in beautiful
diverse mexico this is the largest
and most diverse open world ever in a
forza horizon game
and there is no better car to explore it
than the stunning
amg project one forza edition
rendered in unparalleled detail and with
ray tracing
in forza vista thanks to the power of
the xbox
series consoles
[Applause]
i've invited along some of the team to
help give you a taste of some of the
amazing content
that's waiting for you in forza horizon
5.
please welcome bill maddie sierra and
don from the forza team
hey mike hey guys what's up hey everyone
hey what's up mike
and we also have abraham with us as well
he's one of the talented actors who will
be appearing in the game
i can't wait to show you what we've been
working on we begin
in the rainforest on an expedition this
is a new campaign mode
in which you set out on an adventurous
journey across mexico
to explore new locations and discover
places for the festival to expand
i'm on the river now we're getting close
there you are
how's the expedition going i'm racing a
car
through the mexican jungle ramming it
doesn't get much better than this
i can see some ruins up ahead yeah
helps look out for the flamingos
the city is still a jewel of mayan
architecture
that's a peek at our adventurous
campaign but forza horizon has always
been a game that's best
enjoyed with others let's go and see
what some of our other players are up to
the xbox series consoles allow us to
capture every last detail
right down to the individual needles on
these choir cactus
the scene looks real but there are no
tricks
this is in-game maddie is behind the
wheel of the amg
project one forza edition in mexico's
lush
living desert the perfect place to meet
up with friends and head out
for a drive thanks to the next
generation of our horizon live servers
everyone else we see here are real
players and it looks like maddie has
been joined by some other members of the
forza team
let's leave maddie for a moment and head
out to the coast and meet don
don is already on the move exploring
this idyllic seaside town
this is a recreation of mexico that is
honest authentic
and filled with love speaking up hold up
dawn
oh hey what's up this is a mural by
mexican artist
farid rueda just one of the many
beautiful
faithful pieces of mexico you'll find
all over forza horizon 5.
[Applause]
while don drives down to the beach we'll
jump over to the grand caldera volcano
check out this geology detail
implemented with precision accuracy
using photogrammetry data captured on
location atop an active
mexican volcano the entire world has
been recreated at this level
of detail and here's sierra in her
favorite off-road boogie
the volcano sierra and friends are
exploring is the highest point
ever in a horizon game and thanks to the
power of the xbox series consoles
from up here we can see from miles in
every direction
in the distance we can just about make
out guanajuato
let's take a closer look guanajuato
is one of the most beautiful cities
anywhere in the world
it's a colorful undulating city full of
vibrant architecture
it even has a sprawling network of
tunnels and these twisting turning
overlapping streets mean as well as
looking good it plays great too
as we see here as don is challenged in
horizon's open world battle royale
the eliminator while don tries to win
that race
the rest of our players are still out
exploring this diverse open world
let's head north to the canyon the
horizon series is known for its
uplifting beauty
and using our unique hdr camera rig we
captured 24-hour shoots of real mexican
skies at 12k resolution
and thanks to the xbox series consoles
these photo realistic skies
result in lifelike lighting that
dynamically changes every frame
making you feel like you're really there
here's maddie again she's joined by
abraham and some other members of the
team
our players are using forza link the new
ai assistant that intelligently tracks
the status of you
and the people you meet online and then
helps you link up and play together
we'll now head deep into the rainforest
and rejoin bill and the rest of our
players
here we see our new volumetric lighting
system filling the scene with god rays
as the sunlight dapples through the
dense rainforest
a horizon arcade minigame is about to
start forza link knows that bill loves
mini games
so it intelligently prompts sierra to
invite bill bill accepts and they're
seamlessly linked together with their
gps route set
with that horizon arcade mini game
starting soon all of our players are
coming together
this mini game is called pinata pop
signaled by the horizon cargo plane
dropping a payload of pinatas
ooh over this way gotta catch up to you
guys
power players now have to work together
to find and pop
as many as they can okay go up here to
the left there's loads along the main
road
here we go i'll take a look through the
bushes here
there's some between the houses
there's a couple more over here while
the team grabbed those last few pinatas
we're going over to the stadium because
i have one more thing to show you
this is events lab the incredible
new tool set that allows you to create
your own races
game modes and gameplay experiences you
customize everything
right down to the fundamental rules of
the game
forza horizon 5 is the largest most fun
and most beautiful
open world we've ever built and it will
truly be an astounding showcase for the
xbox series consoles when it comes to
xbox game pass
this november 9th thank you so much i'll
see you all in mexico
later this year
team xbox is on a